peu télé
des photos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eh bien bonjour je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver sur tf1 il ira anne marie
peysson dans quelques instants avec moi
et nous espérons toute l'équipe d'avis
de recherche
eh bien vous apporter le soleil que vous
n'avez peut-être pas dans votre région
j'espère que ça va bien chez vous alors
immédiatement regardez la photo
d'arrivée sont sur votre écran
c'est anne marie peysson vous allez
peut-être être un peu étonné car c'est
pas tout à fait un mari que vous
connaissez c'est le lycée montgrand vous
allez l'avoir anne-marie parce que roger
palin va faire un gros plan dannemarie
le lycée montgrand 1950 à marcel lavoie
l'âme
regardez là alors si vous vous
reconnaissez sur cette photo si vous
croyez reconnaître quelqu'un de votre
entourage familial professionnel ou
amical et bien dès maintenant appeler le
538 66 33
ainsi au fil des semaines et de cet été
pluvieux mais ça va s'arrêter j'en suis
sûr
nous allons essayer de reconnaître de
retrouver de réunir les amis de classe
de plusieurs vedettes
anne-marie nous a fait l'amabilité de
faire la première émission essuie les
plâtres comme on dit et j'espère que
tout va bien se passer
nous sommes ici en direct au studio 101
à paris anne marie va pas on ne va pas
faire les présentations carnot
neuf années de de télévision de radio
pour un mari besson et puis des
fabriques depuis combien de temps tu
chantes vous avez vous conscience ça
fait trop souvent de vieillir me disant
que le défi tant que ça marche comme on
dit ça va faire six ans voilà alors
regardez regardez cette ce bouquet de
fleurs regarder ses lumières car si
lumière ça veut tout simplement dire que
nous avons quelqu'un qui a appelé le 538
66 33
donc qu'ils étaient avec nous à marie en
classe à l'eau alors qu'ils étaient
l'appareil rit elle était blonde mince
c'est bien ça m'arrive avec qui avait
l'air sur mensonge avait l'air très
timide
c'était très douce une de mes cousines
qui te ressemblent beaucoup et j'ai
souvent pensé à toi
anne-marie si vous êtes d'accord
il ya deux ans marie la pêche sont
écoulons anne marie coulon si vous êtes
d'accord vous allez nous dire le numéro
que vous portez sur la photo qui est sur
l'écran maintenant de façon à ce qu'il
soit lisse bien de co2 est mort trois au
deuxième rang à l'extrême droite ont du
mal à passer
ça s'est passé quand cette photo il y
avait un cours de mathématiques est ce
qu'il y avait avant
ona l'once s'était c'était en général
pendant la récréation à qu'on nous
faisait une photo tous les qu'est-ce que
tu es devenu anne marie
oui abonde formidable à la musicienne
âgées dans les percussions de strasbourg
mari il est dans les percussions de
strasbourg pour rien qu'est-ce qu'il
joue au formidable et tu as des enfants
bon ça c'est bien tu sais pas ce que moi
j'ai jamais su en faire quatre réussis
jean-pierre iso quel âge tu vois j'ai
toujours été en retard par rapport à
vous autres
michael caine marie peysson travail est
bien en place
[Musique]
moi j'aime y avait bien certainement une
matière obligatoire
le français on se souvient de la tirade
du nez de cyrano
oui on peut le faire comme ça là c'est
pareil d'avancé tout à fait appropriés
en fin de vie encore
il perd campe éléphanteaux camelo ce
changement c'est vrai mais là c et puis
je suis très intimité là c'est normal
c'est normal à nice où l'on vous savez
que vous êtes là henri jayer on pourrait
dire oh dieu bien des choses encore par
exemple tenez agressif moi monsieur si
j'avais un tel n'est il faudrait sur le
champ que je me rende plus tu as amical
mais il doit tremper dans votre tasse
pourboires fait fabriquer 1 ap
descriptif c'est un roc s'est pas pic
c'est un cap que dis-je c'est un cap
c'est une péninsule ses mots
[Applaudissements]
j'ai devant moi une comme on appelle ça
dénote un livret a vu ses prix une fois
que je vais à livrer des données
françaises est intéressant est ce qu a
dit votre ami en arrive à ça se prouve
assez vrai sauf que marc et sciences
physiques ou naturels et tours 10 je ne
sais pas pas très gentil et étudier et
parfois peu attentive même y avait une
dame où monsieur bon élève qui peut
remercier anne marie toujours ne nous
voient rappelés et c'est grâce à notre
confrère télérama qui a publié une autre
photo que vous vous êtes reconnu je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez toujours
continuer à nous appeler au 530 8 66 33
et si vous avez sur le cadran
téléphoniques des lettres et bien ça
correspond également à jeu j e u
je 66 33 tiens qu'est-ce qui se passe
car à coup de fil
alors ça veut dire que au 530 8 66 33 il
ya encore un autre appel à l'eau et oui
qui est au bout du fil
je tiens compris comment le vit mon
vicari c'était une championne de
natation bonjour je suis contente de
temps de tendre
c'était une très jolie fille qui avait
surtout à nantes était peut-être
formidable en natation
mais je sais pas si tu t'en souviens
attend en garde anne marie on regarde
directement le numéro d'amm sur la photo
qui alors ça dès le 16 sept
c'est bien c'est ok elle avait des
cheveux magnifiques que je rêvais dans
ses cheveux parce qu'elle est aussi
blonde que j'étais brune et pour moi
c'était l'exotisme quoi et on a été même
assez à ses copines toutes les deux une
année on a on a cette année là
d'ailleurs on était à côté en classe et
je crois que j'étais très bonne élève
ouest était bien mais c'était facile de
concilier les études sérieuses stella
maris et
le sport la natation pas ce que vous
faisiez déjà de la natation and mais tu
étais championne des championnes de
france oui mais racontez nous un petit
peu pendant en quelle année en 48 et
championne du 100 m dos du 200 m brasse
libreka n'est pas d'accord et vous avez
toujours bien nager dans votre vie aussi
amsa ça marche bien et là maintenant tu
es tu nages ou pas maintenant je
travaille dans une compagnie aérienne à
paris ah bon alors tout à l'air anne
marie coulon et tend à strasbourg toi tu
les as paris alors j'espère que ça nous
donnera l'occasion de nous revoir alors
tué des gens sentent aussi moi c'est
toujours le problème croissant de quel
âge alors général à épiler les jumeaux
car son fils qui rend 18 ans et
coriandre et rappelle mais dis donc
pourquoi c'est nous et ranger les
meilleurs en italien en a aux etats-unis
non mais ça c'est je suis très diva
après bon d'accord bon parlons d'autre
chose
alors non mais ça arrive comme ça dans
la vie ce n'est pas bien grave
dites-moi est-ce que vous seriez
d'accord pour venir vendredi
ici en direct au style de soi retrouver
anne marie peysson oui c'est pas
difficile voire peut-être les à paris
parce que vous savez claire et al marri
le sait très bien c'est un petit peu la
mission que tu nous as donné on se
tutoie c'est normal c'est de retrouver
et puis de réunir ici le vendredi tous
ceux qui ont fait partie de ta classe au
lycée montgrand 1950 on verra vendredi à
l'arrière au revoir merci d'avoir
rappelé comment vous faites oui alors à
l'eau tout de suite en permanence mais
dites moi ça 538 66 33 et qui est un
appareil encore halo halo qui est la
raclée de manière jacqueline mieux bravo
jour j'ai vu comment oui oui mais quel
but alors là je suis trop loin ça y est
c'est fini la vieillerie j'y vois plus à
quels numéros et le numéro trois et
numéro 3 1 2 3 1 là bas vous êtes sur la
même rangée qu'elle m'avait fait son
malin ya jeanine de la cendre olivieri
annie péri
après quoi la lacune manière vous
habitez ou encore maintenant à marseille
grâce à grasse annonce assez écoeurant
et pourquoi parce que c'est trop beau
quelle question jean plus a dit
jacqueline qu'ils t'ont fait il
aujourd'hui à grasse alors toi qu'est ce
que tu fais tu étais au sol
vous avez exercé une profession jeté un
voile a remporté dans six ont appareils
encore ça vous pouvez constater que
commencer est ce que tu te souviens
comment tu commencé comme ça oui
là vraiment la vedette là est ce que
vous avez jacqueline assez difficile
avec de fabas je pourrai jamais parlé
est ce que tu en es ce que vous avez
jacqueline suivi la carrière d'un
vaisseau avec une autre vie qui d'eau
très bien dis moi tu vas pouvoir venir
tu viens vendre plus parce que avec vous
venez avec votre guitare parce que je
crois que vous apprenez vous apprennent
à jouer de la guitare
est-ce que vous souvenez du temps ça
c'est mon petit doigt qui me l'a dit du
temps où vous étiez avec anne-marie je
crois y avait une équipe
le thème aux guides de france ah oui tu
étais guide c'est vrai la 10e avec chefs
tels denise rémusat ti oui je suis resté
en relation tu serres est claire oui bon
on parlera de tout ça vendredi que la
capote ont tout m
moi j'étais plus jeune et pas de thème
moi j'ai eu beaucoup de difficultés a
pas d'affaires ma promesse et j'étais
dans l'équipe des fauvettes
elle avait pas de thème à marie
jacqueline bienvenue à vendredi d'accord
enfin 2 538 66 33 68 66 33 jusqu'à ce
soir 19 heures
car du lundi au vendredi vous pouvez
venir effectivement nous appeler et puis
venir le vendredi nous rejoindre ici
si vous faites partie de la classe
d'anne marie peysson vous savez que dave
a fait ses études prédisent versoo nous
en parlerons demain il sera le 18
juillet à maubeuge dans le cadre de la
fête de la bière
nous parlerons nous parlons beaucoup
avec dave demain car il sera également
parmi nous je vous propose maintenant
d'écouter notre générique et d'applaudir
très fort anne marie peysson élèves qui
ont bien voulu participer à cette
première émission
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ajaccio
[Musique]
sabatier c'est aura connaissez
tu t'appelais
pour le verre de l'amitié à la télé
[Musique]